[Music]
a michael jackson impersonator puts a
man in a chokehold i said this to joe
because i knew joe was gonna like this
did you see this we will watch this
video right now
you saw this i [ __ ] shared it on my
stories baby ow oh press play
look at the positions look at the
position yeah
you're going for triangles
it's not funny thinking it's actually
michael jackson i don't know
what zombies playing in the background
is it beanie bear i don't want it to be
beat it so bad
trains though
you could tell you trained yo when this
video came out i was [ __ ] dying right
but the comments right people are
hilarious this fool said
[Laughter]
stupid there's no kid
he's probably tired of all the bullies
just [ __ ] coming up to him all the
time because they think
michael jackson impersonator in las
vegas took down this man who claims
he slapped him while he's trying to work
like imagine imagine trying to do your
imagine trying to do your mj
impersonation and some guy comes with a
slap
that's [ __ ] up dude
yeah that's pretty rude
that kind of happened to bart one time
he was at he was at a club uh we were
doing like a meet and greet type of [ __ ]
he was at a club uh oh in a fan slap yes
so then
he went to go to the bathroom so i was
just chilling and then he comes back he
goes uh so this girl wanted to take a
picture with me but like first she
slapped me and then asked me to take a
picture was a girl that's what i [ __ ]
hate san jose
you got people saying
[Laughter]
that's the san jose hello it was like
one of those like events at like this
club in san jose and i just went to go
take a piss and then someone was like oh
my biggest fan oh koi turn around and
whack did i slap you hard yeah
it was so like it stunned me so much i
didn't even feel the pain you know what
i mean cause i was just like whoa she
felt arousal
you better not yeah let's go pee and i
just couldn't believe it like i was like
holding my dick at my face at the same
time yeah just going like you should
have checked wait wait wait wait wait
dick was out with the girl slapped you
no what school i said what what was the
how did that make sense it does it i
still don't know what happened you
didn't see the flyer said slap your
favorite influencer
that's how they booked the that's what
they paid us all your better managers
what you need bro that's why they paid
us so good that you ever had like a
weird ass fan experience
somebody tried to box you real quick no
i think
it's i mean it's not weird but
i remember he came up to me
and he couldn't [ __ ] speak
i was like
it's all good
yeah you're a nice guy man
he gave him the thumbs
when you get more and more like known
right as a fighter they always get
challenged like if you go out at night
go to a bar or whatever like dudes just
want to get famous because like you hit
them or like they want to sue you and
they trap you and [ __ ] you ever think
about [ __ ] like that
like when you go out with your friends
and they're like cause you're like a
lethal weapon like [ __ ] conan not
about that about fighting dudes out but
like well girls i always think about
that oh like they're like oh i'm
pregnant oh yeah because you know
athletes always have like 20 kids and
[ __ ] so that's like that's good to think
about that like mayweather he got like
he has a whole like staff of wives you
know he has like a staff staff of lights
yeah i feel like he has a hairline he
got a union he's not a staff but you
know it's a it's it's a group it's a
collective it's a collective of
girlfriends and wives you know the
mayweather collective yeah he's married
to all of them i don't know i think he's
married
i knew the answer was no but i went oh
no
sugar daddy to a lot of people oh yeah
so this dude is santana as his actual
name when he's not the king of pop we
went to see him he is actually a
wrestler yeah so like this will do what
he's doing and he actually uh puts him
to school until the guy's eyes close and
then bystanders like hey yo he's out no
cuz he knows what he was doing did a leg
trip he got a neon belly you explaining
[ __ ] brown belt yeah bro it's a neon
belly that sounds like a salamander he
tripped him down but if i give him a
critique you know he didn't hold him
down that guy was like he was flailing
he was like really drunk you're gonna
hold that guy down he's not slacking you
should never you should never let that
guy roll to his belly dude you try
moonwalking for [ __ ] four hours
straight see if you can do that that's
true if you guys could teach me how to
moonwalk anthony ryan than maybe
you guys haven't even offered since i've
been here i like watching people in
costume in real fights
like i saw one dude the spiderman the
spider the spiderman the batman guy yeah
the spiderman and batman and new york or
whatever they were getting down dude
real fight spider-man real fight yeah it
was like two on one have you ever seen
those videos no oh dude when you said
like a constant fight i was like [ __ ]
mortal kombat or something
like the avengers besides boxing do you
watch any other like fight sports or
anything like do you ever see those
russian fights where six guys fight six
guys those are nuts the brawls oh yeah
they're all like fields out in the
middle of nowhere like snow for no
reason yeah dude not but from time to
time like some randomized tick tocks
will pop up on my feet of like backyard
boxing or something oh yeah those those
are those are so popular
people love that [ __ ] man there's that
have you guys seen the russian parkour
fighting
hardcore they're fighting on like
imagine like a real-life 3d super mario
wing yeah you're trying to beat each
other if you knock someone out this dude
can fall six feet down into a foam pit
because it's like this so you gotta
climb and it's like i've not seen that
i've only seen the the tag one yeah
what is that called i need to look that
up russian parkour championship it's
always russian it's all russians are
always doing some wild [ __ ] dude there's
one of uh there's a new one that's
everyone's arena combat i think it's
called arena combat or they do jiu jitsu
in the backseat of a car
i've seen that
yes
uh are you sure that's not just bang
bush
actually that's what it was my bad
forget all that that's that's what i
thought it was i saw it though but
there's no
there's even ones where you box in a
phone booth like actually
like
you ever seen this [ __ ] no my algorithm
is so different how do you even find the
phone but
that's what they have to pay you to do
phone booth boxing look i know for some
reason i feel like i'll be kind of good
at that bro you'd be so good at that are
you kidding me he's got he's knocking
everybody out
what are you talking about
yeah one
dog they're not even doing parkour dude
you guys just getting jumped yo is it
like three on three and [ __ ] yo
you get to jump and like fall down oh
okay oh dang it takes a certain kind of
people to want to do this bro that
sounds kind of fun it's kind of tight
that it's teams yeah yeah right
it's like five times i wanna do it i
don't even know how you tried
if you had if you had to do a two-on-two
boxing match who would your teammate be
friends
who drawn enes what was your question i
said if he had to do a two-on-two boxing
match who would his teammate be
drum that dudes dudes yeah he's good
he's a 147 pounder yeah how would his
style complement what you have bring to
the table um
i feel like
i told you guys earlier uh i told you
guys this earlier but i feel like i
already have them like on my pound for
pilot so like one of the best fighters
out there out of all the weight classes
um
just because he could fight this way he
could fight this way a lot of people can
only fight one way
and i mean he's a good good boxer good
puncher good speed good power
damn you didn't know what he just said
stop it hey first of all this is like
southpaw
i don't know that's regular bro this is
like north pole
oh damn north i like that i like the
finesse in his shoulders all right watch
out i'm a north pole
now i'm about to [ __ ] look up phone
booth boxing dude that is nuts and then
they also do the uh they do one where
they arm wrestle and they start boxing
each other like this
guess what all russians dude they're all
russian i like that slap competition oh
we're trying to knock the other dude
crazy they got the chalk on their hands
and stuff they like warm up to it have
you seen the chicks do it yeah i don't
know how they three guys like
don't flinch
you know what i mean like because they
because they're not a [ __ ]
i know i'm such a [ __ ] they go like
this yeah they line up like this and
they just
i naturally want to like all right this
is this is [ __ ] ridiculous i don't
even
know that's so crazy i don't even know
what to say to you that looks like some
british [ __ ] man
is it just because yo why does it look
like my buddy dairy like what oh they're
all tied
up is this boy oh
how is this even enjoyable look at that
the guy's got a little bit on the
outside
i was just gonna say that like if you
want to get your close quarter combat
that's [ __ ] close [ __ ] would you
implement any of these training tactics
ever
he's like you don't think it's useful
brandon's gonna buy a phone booth later
today
or how realistic is that thing in the
the scene and uh what is it creed where
you got to put your foot in like a tire
and everybody says mad close
no
hollywood [ __ ] same thing as that you
know to be honest
i really don't like boxing movies to be
they suck man did you like creed how
come you don't like boxing i didn't like
it i don't like boxing movies it's too
fake or i think it's just too fake um
yeah i think it's just too fake or like
i know what like a real boxer does
and
i do have favorite boxing movies yeah
what's the closest one that like
actually captures bloodsport
not even boxing i don't know about one
that actually like captures everything
but bleed for this with uh
i think it's on uh mickey word
and then there's another one with mark
off i think it's called a fighter oh my
god oh that one
is that with christian bale yeah yeah
that one's ty he's dicky i like fight
club
fight club that's my favorite boxing
movie
[Music]
you